Well, this evening's lecture is about
the battle of the Bibles. We won't
really be going into the Bible directly
tonight. We'll be looking at the history
in this battle, and tomorrow night we'll
be looking at the Bible itself.
So, don't forget to bring your Bibles
tomorrow night. What is this battle all
about?
You will know that in the past, the
Bible was a very, very
important issue,
and there were wars fought over this
Bible,
and the church of the Middle Ages banned
the Bible,
and today everybody seems quite
satisfied that everybody has a Bible.
So, has attitude changed, or has
something else changed?
Matthew chapter 4 verse 4. But he
answered and said, "It is written, man
shall not live by bread alone,
but by every word that proceeds out of
the mouth of God."
I quote that from the King James
version, or else I'd have a problem. I'd
only be able to read half the verse to
you.
But, uh, nevertheless, it says,
"It is written, man shall not live by
bread alone, but by every word that
proceedeth out of the mouth of God."
Obviously, it's important that we know
the word of God.
Isaiah chapter 8 verse 20 says,
"To the law and to the testimony,
if they speak not according to this
word,
it is because there is no light in
them."
In other words, if you do not speak
according to the word of God,
and if you do not speak according to the
testimony, that which the prophets have
iterated regarding God's actions, which
had to be in harmony with the Torah, the
first five books of the Bible, then
there is no light in them. So, don't
come with something contrary to the word
of God. Revelations 22 verse 18 says,
"For I testify unto every man that
heareth the words of the prophecy of
this book, if any man shall add unto
these things,
God shall add unto him the plagues that
are written in this book.
And if any man shall take away from the
words of the book of this prophecy, God
shall take away his part out of the book
of life,
and out of the holy city, and from the
things which are written in this book."
That's pretty serious.
Don't mess with the word of God. Would
you agree that that's basically what it
says?
That's a pretty serious accusation.
And obviously, if man does not live by
bread alone, but by every word which
proceeds out of the mouth of God, if you
add to it and take away from it, and
jumble it around, and change it, this
could be problematic. Now, today we have
many Bibles,
and there are hosts of translations of
the Bibles. Now, which one is the best?
They will tell you that the modern ones
are the best, and yes, in many ways,
with the modern Greek scholarship, a lot
of the verses in the modern Bibles have
better translations than in the old
versions, because of better knowledge of
the Greek terminology.
But,
if the grammar is improved, does that
necessarily mean that the context have
has to be improved or changed? That's
when you get into trouble.
So, what is the family tree of the
modern Bibles which we have in the world
today?
The original manuscripts of all Bibles
have been lost. They don't exist
anymore. So, all we have is copies of
copies. Some of them are very old, some
of them are less old.
And there are basically three, although
we will actually see there are only two,
really, streams of Bibles.
The ones that are, uh,
at the base, in other words, the oldest
ones, are all lost manuscripts. So, they
are all copies of previous manuscripts.
Now,
as far as the Bible that led to the King
James version in the English language,
they come from the central tree. These
are like they are lost manuscripts of
the traditional text,
and they come basically from the Syriac,
from the Gothic virgin versions. There's
a codex W and a codex A, and then there
is a vast majority of extant texts,
which make up the New Testament
manuscripts, and we're talking about
1,900
manuscripts
in this central block, from which
eventually we have the King James
version, and every other Bible except
the Roman Catholic and the Jesuit Bible,
every single Bible in the world that was
written before 1940.
Every single one comes from here.
Then there are two other streams. The
one is the, uh,
the one that led to the Douay version,
which is basically the Jesuit version.
And the ancestor of Western family, that
is lost, and the text is an expansion of
an original text, and there you have the
Old Latin version. You have the Latin
Vulgate version, which the Pope declared
to be infallible. You have codex D,
codex D2, codex E2, and the Douay
version of 1582,
which was written to counteract the
Reformation. That's the one stream.
And manuscripts belonging to the same
family have the same text. They all
agree closely in the wording.
Then there's another tree, which is the
ancestor of the Alexandrian family,
and the original is also lost, of
course, as we see. And there you have a
few interesting documents, and these are
relatively new, but they are old
documents. They have been found lately.
Papyrus 75, codex B, are two of them.
Then you have papyrus 66, and then the
most famous of them all, codex Aleph.
And from this very small stream of four
manuscripts, you have the Revised
Version, the American Standard Version,
the Revised Standard Version, and the
New English Bible, and all the hosts of
new ones that are coming out in
all the languages of the world, are
based on these manuscripts over here.
So, in the central block, you have
thousands of manuscripts,
but the this particular one over here,
codex Aleph,
is one of the very oldest that there is,
and of course, the Old Latin versions
and the Vulgate also based on relatively
old documents. Now,
so all of them come from old documents.
The oldest ones that we have come from
this stream over here.
Does old necessarily mean good?
Today, we equate old with good. Now, old
does not necessarily mean good. That's a
very important point to remember. If we
look at the central one over here, with
thousands of copies in
all the languages of the world, just
about, then this is a very interesting
point. If I have a franchise,
let's say I have developed a new brand
of chicken to sell to someone,
and I have a wonderful recipe, which I'm
now going to base a franchise on, and I
send it to every country in the world,
and they're going to follow this recipe
by the letter, and we're going to sell,
uh, blue pumpkin chicken, or whatever,
in this franchise.
Now, everybody gets the original recipe,
and diligently translates it because the
Germans need it in German, and the
Portuguese need it in Portuguese, and
the Spanish in Spanish, etc. So, each
one diligently copies it. And now there
are literally thousands of copies in
various languages of the original one
that was written and sent out. Over the
years, the original one gets copied so
many times that it it falls apart. So,
all you have is copies. That's all you
have.
And then one day, somebody says to
himself, you know, that's a pretty good
recipe. I wish I could just change it a
little bit and steal the franchise for
myself.
So, he alters the recipe
and says, "Hello, folks. I've got the
original recipe. Here it is." And then
he burns it a little bit and makes it
look old and what have you. Not that
this happened there, but anyway, he's
got the original the original recipe.
And he starts his franchise with the new
recipe. Now, everybody says, "Well,
which one is now the original one? This
one or that one?" This is highly
problematic. Now we have two.
Which one is the right one? Well, what
do you do?
You say, "Now, hang on a second. The
original one has been copied and
translated in so many different
languages. Let's get the German one and
the Spanish one and the Greek one and
the this one and the Armenian one and
the Serbian one, and we'll check it
out." And lo and behold, they all agree
with this one but not with that one.
Which one was then the original one?
The one that has the cloud of witnesses
supporting it. Yes or no?
Okay. And that you'll find only in the
central stream. There's a cloud of
witnesses in the central stream. I mean,
there are just 1,900 documents there
alone that all agree. Now, the originals
have been copied so many times they're
gone.
But, and now this is interesting.
In this stream over here, there are many
verses gone. Just absolutely gone.
And in this stream over here, there are
many verses that are just gone that are
in this stream over here.
Now, we don't have the original
manuscripts. So, the the the followers
of this stream say,
"Aha, they weren't in the original.
After all, these are old documents." And
this stream says they weren't in the
original.
You see what they're saying?
But, what if
you had very ancient letters from the
church fathers, which often obviously
weren't as copied as much as the Bible
was as a document. And you have very
ancient letters from very ancient church
fathers writing to each other. Now, if I
write a letter to my wife, for example,
I'm sitting in this country and she's in
another country and I write her a nice
letter and I'm encouraging her, giving
her a few quotes out of the Bible.
That everybody does, isn't that so? So,
we have these ancient letters and there
are quotes of verses
which don't happen to appear there.
But the letters are older than those
manuscripts. Then which one would be the
right one?
Which one would you suggest? Then
obviously the ones that are in line with
here, the center, because they're
quoting verses that don't even exist in
those. And that is the case. That's how
it is.
So, why do we have these three streams
and what is it all about?
Now, Kurt Aland, who is co-editor of
both of the most widely used critical
Greek texts and who is certainly the
leading textual scholar on the European
continent, proposes that the texts of
P75 and B in that Alexandrian stream
represent a revision of a local text of
Egypt which was enforced as the dominant
text in that area.
So, basically, we don't have four, we
just have two, and the one is just a
modification of the other. So,
basically, there's just one document
in that left stream, and that is that
Sinaiticus text. We'll come to that in a
moment.
Then David Otis says, "Fundamentally,
there are only two streams of Bibles.
The first stream, which carried the
received text in Hebrew and Greek,
precious manuscripts were preserved by
such as the church at Pella
in Palestine, where Christians fled when
in 70 AD the Romans destroyed Jerusalem.
So, the original manuscripts
were not in Rome, they came from the
Christian area. They came from
Jerusalem, they came from Syria, there
where the apostles preached. That's
where the original manuscripts were, and
that's the logical place for them to be
because that's where the apostles were,
isn't that right?
By the Syrian Church of Antioch, which
produced eminent scholarship, by the
Italic Church in northern Italy, and
also, by the way, the Christians in
northern Italy previously received their
scriptures from the Middle Eastern route
and not from Rome.
And there was a major problem between
the Ostrogoths and those in Rome because
they had different scriptures. Very
interesting. So, northern Italy had the
same as those in the Middle Eastern
regions. And also, at the same time, by
the Gallic Church in southern France and
by the Celtic Church in Great Britain,
the pre-Waldensians and the Waldensians
and the Reformation, they all had the
same basic manuscripts.
These manuscripts have in agreement with
them the vast majority of all the copies
of the original text. So, that central
stream, this is called the received text
or the Textus Receptus.
So vast is this majority that even the
enemies of the received text admit that
the 19/20th
of all Greek manuscripts are of this
class.
Just about everyone is of that class.
Then there's a second stream,
which is a very small one and is based
on ancient manuscripts. Let's not doubt
that.
And they represent in Greek the Vatican
manuscript or Codex B
in the library at Rome.
And this one was used to counteract the
Reformation because it says different
things to the one that the reformers
used.
So, at the time of of the Reformation,
Codex B became very prominent.
And then we have the Sinaitic text or
Codex Aleph. Now, that is one that was
found in Alex- in the region of Egypt.
Uh I'll show you the place later, and it
comes from an Alexandrian text.
So, we have this one, and it was found
in a very interesting date. It was found
in 1844.
1844.
So, this is the youngest find of all the
ancient manuscripts, and it is a very
old document.
So, when it says in your new Bibles that
this translation is
based on ancient manuscripts, then the
idea is planted that ancient means good.
Are you with me?
But ancient doesn't necessarily mean
good. It just means ancient.
That's all it means.
In Latin, there's the Vulgate or Latin
Bible of Jerome, 383 AD. That's pretty
old.
And uh there are some problems with that
as we will see just now as well. In
English,
there's the Jesuit Bible of 1582. That
was written in the vulgar tongue, if you
like, to counteract the Reformation
Bible,
which later, with vast changes, is seen
in the Douay or Catholic Bible, which is
the one on which the Good News Bible and
all of those are based today, and in
English again in many modern Bibles.
So,
this controversy, as we see here, each
each statement I make will have a quote
so that nobody says again I say so. I
say nothing, I just read.
The present controversy between the King
James Bible in English and the modern
version is the same all contents fought
out between the early church rival
sects. So, the early church had this
battle
because these ancient manuscripts are
different.
And the modern church has this battle.
So, both of them had the battle. There
was a battle in the beginning. There was
a war in the middle when the Reformation
came up, a literal war eventually over
this word. And now we have another
battle looming in our time, the final
battle. This will be the last one, I
think.
That's my opinion.
So,
the battle was waged between the
Waldenses and the papists from the 4th
to the 13th century and later between
the reformers and the Jesuits in the
16th century. And today the battle is
going to be waged between whoever
represents
the Bibles that these people also
defended and whoever represents the
other side.
We need to understand that many of the
new translations are taken from old
manuscripts, no doubt, as I've
explained.
People think that these are more
reliable. No, they're just old.
In actual fact, they are saying, now
listen carefully,
that a manuscript that was found in a
wastepaper basket in a cave at Mount
Sinai
and questionable manuscripts from
Alexandria, where you had all this
occultism, are more reliable than the
received text. That's what they're
saying.
So, these questionable ones are more
reliable. In fact, the one found at
Mount Sinai was thrown away because it
had been copied over, rubbed out, and
judging by the
the science of looking at how many times
pieces had been rubbed out and
rewritten, it seems that it has been
rubbed out and rewritten in many places
up to 70 times. In fact, it was so
rubbed out and rewritten that they threw
it away.
But, that is the manuscript on which
everything is based today as reliable.
Now, where do these manuscripts come
from? Now, there's a man by the name of
Origen who was an old initiate. We'll
find him in the Masonic writings as an
insider initiate. That's interesting. If
I find somebody praised in the Masonic
writings, my ears prick up.
He was a textual critic, and he's
supposed to have corrected numerous
portions of the sacred manuscripts. Now,
this is in ancient ancient times.
Evidence to the contrary shows that he
changed them to agree with his human
philosophy
of mystical and allegorical ideas. For
example, he believed that man was
divine,
and therefore there was not just one
divine man that came to this earth. We
are all divine, which is Masonic
teaching even to this day.
And so, they believe that these
manuscripts actually were corrupted.
So, from the birth of Christ to about
400 AD,
some Gnostic gospels appeared,
and other writings were written. Paul
makes mention of this, and he says in 2
Corinthians 2:17,
"For we are not as many which corrupt
the word of God."
So, in Paul's time, were they corrupting
the word of God? Yes or no?
Yes, they were corrupting
it, and they were corrupting it with
Gnostic ideas.
And this is to bring them in line with
an ecumenical thinking that all
religions are basically the same. We
shouldn't elevate one above another.
In 331 AD, and this is where the problem
really starts now.
Constantine
ordered an ecumenical Bible.
You see, Christianity
was saying
"Jesus is the way, the truth, and the
life."
And all the doctrines regarding to
Christianity were problematic because
they were in the face of paganism.
And so, Constantine, who tried to marry
the two,
he commissioned a man by the name of
Eusebius, who was by the way a follower
of Origen,
to write an ecumenical Bible.
That is to change the word of God using
Gnostic writings so that it would be
acceptable to pagans as well as to
Christians. And that's what they did.
But, the early Christians rejected these
manuscripts and said, "They are not from
God."
And so, they went into secret libraries,
and there they lay.
Later to be dug up as ancient
manuscripts. There were about 50 copies
made by Eusebius, and they were
distributed, and they ended up largely
in two areas, namely in Rome
and in Alexandria, where you had the
esoteric
um studies.
For example, you know, we'll go into
that a little bit later.
And Origen believed in the so-called
Arian heresy. Now, the Arian heresy
is that Jesus was not God.
And uh that
God is basically, if you like, a form of
pantheistic God in everything. So, we
basically could also
have a divine spark in us, which is
Masonic teaching.
Now, it's interesting that Roman
Catholicism claims that it's anti-Arian,
and that it fought wars and destroyed
people that were Arian.
There is no evidence, let me tell you
now,
there is no historic evidence that the
nations that were destroyed because they
were Arian, like the Ostrogoths for
example or the Vandals,
that they were actually Arian because we
have none of their writings. Every piece
of their literature has been destroyed.
We only have the word of Roman
Catholicism that they were Arian.
But now, I have some interesting news
for you.
Remember I told you yesterday that the
Templars have two doctrines.
One is exoteric, and one is
esoteric. One is for the for the
cattle, and one is for the insiders.
Now, the gospel to the outside is
non-Arian,
but the insider gospel of Roman
Catholicism is Arian. Now, what do you
do with that?
And how do I know that it's Arian?
It's because the Pope has declared the
Vulgate
as an infallible Bible, and the Vulgate
is Arian.
It removes the deity of Christ. Isn't
that interesting? So, what's the battle
about?
The battle is about Jesus Christ, just
as it was since prehistory.
The battle is about the son of God.
And who are we going to defend?
Jesus or someone else? So, this is an
interesting battle. I find this a
fascinating battle.
1481 AD, the Vatican manuscript was
discovered in the Vatican library. Isn't
that interesting? Just in time to
counter the Reformation.
Just in time.
Because the Reformation was using the
received text. There was no other text.
So, you must now believe that up until
1481,
God had kept the truth
of the Bible away from all generations
up to 1481. They all were based on wrong
manuscripts. And fortunately,
the Vatican discovered the right
manuscript in 1481 to counter the
Reformation.
And this manuscript repeatedly sets
aside the deity of Christ, and it's
Arian.
So, that is insider doctrine. This is
Templar doctrine because we saw it
yesterday
in the lecture that we did yesterday.
And it is probably a manuscript that
survived from Eusebius.
And by the way, this one and the one
that they found at Sinai
are birds of a feather that flock
together. They are very much the same.
So, that's why there are basically only
two streams.
The vast majority, Textus Recepticus,
and then the stream.
And then the magic date, 1844.
The Sinaitic manuscript is discovered at
Mount Sinai in a monastery in St.
Catherine's.
Very interesting. That's the old Coptic
Church, which is basically the Eastern
Byzantine Church, which was exactly the
same as Catholicism because they were
one in the same.
And it agrees absolutely with the
Vatican manuscript,
and it is totally Arian.
By 1881,
two professors from Britain, Westcott
and Hort, created the Greek text,
and uh this is based, of course, on
these manuscripts, on the Vatican
manuscript and the Sinai manuscript,
leaning heavily on the Sinai manuscript
so that it wouldn't appear too overly
Catholic. Are you with me? Doesn't
appear too overly Catholic because these
were
Protestants. Well, let's rather say they
were supposedly Protestants.
And the Jehovah's Witness Bible was then
changed as a result of this new writing.
Now, this was in the early 1900s when
these things started coming out, and the
Jehovah's Witnesses had no other Bible
than the King James.
So, one day, they were told, "Take your
King James Bibles." And as they came in,
they were given a thick black pen, and
they were told, "Now, let's modify the
King James. Cross out, zap, zap, zap,
zap, zap, whatever it is." And they
crossed out. They didn't have their
Bible. It didn't exist in the early
1900s. So, the Jehovah's Witnesses were
the first to just cross out huge
sections of the Bible. I'll show you
that tomorrow night, what they crossed
out.
And it must be emphasized that the
argument is therefore not between an
ancient text and a recent one, but
between two ancient texts. Are you with
me?
That's the argument.
And uh
well, it's an interesting one. Now,
Tyndale,
he, of course, used the received text,
and this really irritated the Vatican
because the other one hadn't been found
yet, by the way.
And he used the received text in his
Bible and said to the Pope, "If God
spare my life before many years, I will
cause a boy that driveth the plow to
know know more about the scriptures than
thou doest."
That was quite a statement.
Once again, I would like to reiterate,
the argument is not King James versus
other versions. The argument is
received text, Textus Recepticus,
versus the small little stream that
comes from Sinai and the Vatican. That's
the argument. By the way,
any Bible in any language
that existed before the 1900s is
received text. So, if you go to Serbia,
they have the received text. If you go
to Greece, they have the received text
in Greek. If you go to any country in
the world, the Lutheran Bible, any
Bible, they're all based on received
text, every single one.
But after 1900,
the modern ones are no longer based on
that.
Well, when this Bible came up, the
Jesuits were called in to help. Big
crisis because now it was plain
that the teaching of Rome was not in
accordance with the Bible.
And this is one of their statements.
Notice what the Jesuits wrote.
We must undermine the Bible of the
Protestants and destroy their teachings.
The Queen of England, realizing the
damage the Jesuit Bible could do, sent
to Europe for Beza, who was with John
Calvin, to help Cartwright to write this
new uh manuscript. Uh he took hold of
the Greek manuscripts and the Latin
manuscripts from the received text, and
he hit the Jesuit Bible blow off the
blow.
So,
war broke out. So, eventually they sent
the Spanish Armada against England to
make war, and they came with 136
armed ships with 50 cannons, and all
England had was a measly 30 ships. These
huge galleys came. They were going to
flatten England because of this Bible.
Well, Sir Francis Drake
got up that morning. He must have been
very nervous.
But what did he find? A storm had come
up in the night, and the Spanish galleys
lay smashed upon the shores as high up
as Scotland. The entire
fleet destroyed in the storm.
And all that he had to do was mop up.
And from that day, England became a
great sea power. That's history.
Now, what did the Jesuits say about the
Bible? Here's the quote.
Then the Bible, that serpent which is
with its head erect and eyes flashing
flashing threatens us with its venom
while it trails along the ground, shall
be challenged into a rod changed into a
rod as soon as we are able to seize it.
For three centuries past, this cruel asp
has left us no repose. You well know
with what folds it entwines us and with
what fangs it gnaws us. They hated the
Bible.
The Jesuit catechism, there is the
quote, says,
Question, what if the Holy Scriptures
command one thing and the Pope another
contrary to it? Answer, the Holy
Scriptures must be thrown aside.
What is the Pope? He is the vicar of
Christ, king of kings, lord of lords,
and there's but one judgment seat
belonging to God and the Pope.
That's quite a statement.
Now, what does Freemasonry say? It's
always nice to have the comparative
documents. Morals and Dogma, the source,
page 818.
Regarding the Bible, Pike writes, "The
absurd reading of the established
church,
taking literally the figurative,
allegorical, and
mythical language of a collection of
oriental books of different ages." Boy,
that's pretty derogatory. "The folly of
regarding the Hebrew books as if they
had been written by the unimaginative,
hard, practical intellect of the England
of James the First and the bigoted
solidity of Scottish Presbyterianism."
Boy, he didn't like that translation. He
hated it. And how did he feel about the
Templars and the Jesuit version? "The
better to succeed and win partisans, the
Templars sympathized with regrets for
dethroned creeds. They sympathized with
paganism
and encouraged the hopes of new
worships, promising to all liberty of
conscience and a new orthodoxy that
should be synthesis of all the
persecuted creeds."
So, you see,
Freemasonry hates the received text. It
has it in its lodge purely as a symbol.
That's so clever. That's so
diabolical, isn't it? That's I forget
it.
Going back to the time of the early
church, we find Coptic versions, Latin
versions, Syrian versions, and they were
circulated long before the Vaticanus
appeared. So, then come two Cambridge
professors who did not even believe in
verbal inspiration of the scriptures,
Westcott and Hort, and they're going to
change everything now.
By the way, Jerome's Bible, which is the
one that is used in the Vatican, the
Latin Vulgate,
how could Helvidius, his contemporary,
have accused Jerome of employing corrupt
Greek manuscripts if Helvidius had not
had pure Greek manuscripts?
So, while Jerome was writing this Latin
Bible, other scholars were already
saying, "Hey, you're using corrupt
manuscripts for this." So, this battle
is an ancient battle. It's not a new
battle.
So, these revised versions are based on
manuscripts from Egypt that were
definitely corrupted. That's what most
of the critics say.
One of the greatest critics of all time
is Dean Burgon.
And when this great man died, then
corruption took hold. He was a bastion.
Burgon writes, "The work of the
evangelists and apostles apostles
recognized as the necessary counterpart
and complement of God's ancient
scripture become the New Testament." And
then he says, "It received as good a
reception as did Jesus Christ himself.
They nailed Jesus to the cross. Would
not they nail his word to the cross as
well?"
That's basically what he says.
"Restless malice and unsparing assaults
against the word of God from the very
beginning." And he What does he say
about these manuscripts that were found?
He says, "We oppose facts to their
speculation. They exalt B and Aleph and
D 8 because in their own opinions these
copies are the best. They weave
ingenious webs and invent subtle
theories because their paradox of a few
against the many requires ingenuity and
subtlety for its support." Very good
writer. He took them apart. We don't
have to read it all. You can stop
the video to have a look at the rest of
the text of what Burgon has to say.
"I am utterly disinclined to believe,"
continues Dean Burgon, "so grossly
improbable does it seem that at the end
of 1,800
years, 995
copies out of every thousand suppose
will prove untrustworthy,
and that the one, two, three, four, or
five which remain, whose contents were
still yesterday as good as unknown, will
be found to have retained the secret of
what the Holy Spirit originally
inspired?"
Interesting point of view.
He further goes on to say, "What in the
meantime is to be thought of those blind
guides, those deluded ones who would
now, if they could, persuade us to go
back to those same codices
of which the church had already purged
herself?"
Go back to those ancient manuscripts.
And he takes Tischendorf, the man who
discovered this manuscript, takes him
apart, takes Tregelles apart, Hort
apart, and uh
shows that he thoroughly disagrees with
their scholarship.
And then this interesting statement,
"Who,
but those with Roman Catholic
sympathies, could ever be pleased with
the notion that God preserved the true
New Testament text in secret
for almost 1,000 years and then finally
handed over to the Roman Pontiff for
safekeeping?"
That's what it boils down to. That's
literally what it boils down to.
Dr. Hoskier quotes from Dr. Salmon. He
says, "Naturally, Hort regarded these
manuscripts as most trustworthy, which
give the reading recognized by Origen."
See? That's what they did. Hort, the
professor
from England, he was an Origen follower.
And we will have to prove that. We can't
just make statements like that. "You
will always be my friend,
but I can no longer ignore the
criticism." This is Dr. Frank Logsdon to
F. Lockman, one of the great translators
himself. "I cannot refute them, and dear
brother, I have not a thing against you,
but the only thing I can do under God is
to renounce every attachment to the New
American Standard Bible."
So, here's one of the committee
detaching himself personally. Well,
let's go to Alexandria and see what we
can find. Here is the statue of Horus,
the secret of the initiated ones.
Horus, Isis, and Dionysius, these
secrets were kept alive at Alexandria,
and the Alexandrian library was world
world famous
for its occult documents.
Then, of course, the very early
Christians, who were Bible-based, got
rid of that
terrible
uh information place, and they burnt the
old Alexandrian library to the ground,
which was a catastrophe for the occult
world. Well, fortunately, UNESCO, this
is very interesting, UNESCO, whose
constitution was written by a Skull and
Bones member, just for instant
interest's sake,
decided to restore it and rebuild it in
exactly the same spot. There it is
today. And the lamps that they've put
down,
they have interesting stuff on them like
little angels carrying cornucopias,
which you discussed yesterday. If you go
and look at the library,
it is huge and it has all the pagan
inscriptions on it that the original
library had on it. It is made according
to the model. All the pagan petroglyphs
and the ancient sun worship symbols are
on it. And this is Demetrius of
Phalerum, the founder of the Alexandrian
library. In it, they still have some of
the ancient manuscripts that happened to
escape. Here you have papyrus of the
zodiac sign, something that the Bible
forbids. Here you have a piece of the
Book of the Dead, which is the Egyptian
Book of the Dead, which is the
counterpart to what the Bible teaches.
It exalts the God of the dead. The Bible
exalts the God of the living.
Then you have these petroglyphs here,
which are too disgusting, so let's just
go away. And they have the deities in
their hexagons and Socrates and ancient
mystic. Socrates, of course, died from
drinking hemlock. He was an initiate and
he released some of the secrets and
according to the oath, if you do that,
you can die of the poison cup if you
choose or you could have your throat
slit from ear to ear and your tongue
ripped out of your mouth. He chose the
hemlock.
The dead are exalted. This library is
absolutely enormous. One cannot even
imagine how big it is.
I made one small video of it. Let's have
a look what it looks like. Just to give
you an idea of the size. It's absolutely
enormous.
And all the interesting pagan symbols
are there.
A total replica of what once must have
existed there.
Well, just to show that I was there
because otherwise people think I wasn't.
Taken from high up in the library. It
was opened by
Mubarak in 2002. It's spanking new.
Spanking new.
I had to go and see it. I had to go and
photograph it. And here they have a
statue of Prometheus bearing the fire.
According to the occult writings, that's
Lucifer, the light bearer. And some of
the symbols on the walls, on the
retaining walls.
Now, let's just have a look at some of
the manuscripts which Rome says are
essential
for
understanding the greater gospel.
And Rome placed the Bible, and that is
only the Textus Receptus, by the way, on
the index of prohibited books. They
didn't place their Vulgate on the index
of prohibited books. It's the Protestant
Bible that they placed there. So, the
early church of Antioch, as I've already
said, used these Syrian manuscripts and
this is a book that is
forbidden by Rome. The Septuagint, on
the other hand, was made for Alexandria,
for the library there. In 285 BC.
So, interesting
data. The apocryphal books,
that means hidden things, the Council of
Trent said the following in 1546,
"Whoever shall not receive as sacred and
canonical all these books and every part
of them as they are commonly read in the
Catholic Church and not contained in the
old Vulgate Latin edition or shall
knowingly and deliberately despise the
aforesaid traditions, let him be
accursed."
So, they said we must accept all of
these manuscripts. Let's briefly run
through them.
Let's go to Tobias 6:4-8,
where it says,
"Open the fish and take the heart and
the liver and the gall. If a devil or an
evil spirit trouble any, we must make a
smoke thereof before the man or the
woman and the party shall no longer be
vexed. As for the gall, it is good to
anoint the man that has whiteness in his
eyes and he shall be healed. So, if you
want to drive away evil spirits, demons,
then wave the gall of a fish and make a
smoke thereof and that will go away."
The Bible says,
"And signs will follow those believing
these things. In my name, they shall
cast out demons." Mark 16:17.
Acts 16:18 says, "Being distressed and
turning to the demon spirit, Paul said,
'I command you in the name of Jesus
Christ to come out of her.' And it came
out that hour." So, he didn't use the
gallbladder of a fish.
Tobias 12:9 says, "For alms does deliver
from death and shall purge away sin."
Oh, that's nice. So, you can pay to get
your sins taken away.
Peter says, "For as much as you know
that you were not redeemed with
corruptible things as silver and gold
from your vain conversation received by
tradition from your fathers."
Two opposing doctrines. Which one is
right? Do you think you can buy your way
to heaven?
Prayer to the dead. Macabees
12:43-46.
"For if he had not hoped that they were
slain, would he have risen again? It had
been superfluous and vain to pray for
the dead.
Whereupon he made reconciliation for the
dead that they might be delivered from
sin." So, you can pray for the dead that
they are delivered from sin?
This is paganism.
John 1:7 says,
"Jesus Christ cleanses us from all sin."
There's no such thing.
That brings us to the Vulgate Bible,
1545 to 1563.
That was the one which was declared
infallible.
Now, what does the Vulgate say? Our
Bible says, "All scripture is God
breathed." The Douay, which is based on
the Vulgate, says, "All scripture that's
inspired of God is profitable."
So, only some scripture is inspired.
Hebrews 11:21
says, "Jacob worshipped as he leaned on
top of his staff." The Vulgate says,
"Jacob adored the top of his rod."
That means you can pray to a relic. You
can pray to a statue. That's where they
get their doctrine from. It also says in
Revelation, in the received text,
"Blessed are they
Oh, no, this is Codex Vaticanus.
"Blessed are they which wash their
robes." But the King James says,
"Blessed are they that do his
commandments."
Now, is the Bible reliable
or is it not?
That is a question that not only affects
our faith, it affects the
doctrine of salvation and it affects the
position of Jesus Christ. We need to
know.
We were talking about the Bible and
where it came from, where the various
manuscripts came from,
and
we have to know whether the Bible is
trustworthy or whether it is not. Well,
the Dead Sea Scrolls, these were
writings meticulously copied by the
Essenes. By the way, they were not
mainline. They were cabalistically
inclined.
And the ancient manuscripts that they
copied were exactly like those found in
the Bible today. So, they actually
supported the Bible. Even the Book of
Daniel meticulously supported by these
ancient manuscripts found in 1949.
So, they proved that the Bible had not
changed in all this time. And these
manuscripts were very exciting. But then
some other
interesting manuscripts have been found
besides this famous uh
one that was found near Alexandria.
And that is a whole series of Gnostic
Gospels. And Time magazine reported on
these some time ago. "Words from the
past. 46 scriptures dug up near Nag
Hammadi in Egypt in 1945
changed views of early Christianity."
Now, interestingly, Egypt was the seat
of the occult science and these were
buried to keep them safe. From who?
Obviously, the early Christianity that
destroyed that ancient pagan library.
And these manuscripts have now been
found since 1945
and are changing the world view. Some
Buddhists are saying, "Had we known that
Christianity had such manuscripts, we
needn't even have been Buddhists."
Well, what do these manuscripts say?
These are the so-called lost gospels
that are so famous today. You have the
Gospel of Thomas, the Gospel of Peter
and all these wonderful manuscripts
throwing light on what the early
Christians believed.
Well,
there were Ebionites, there were
Marcionites, there were Gnostics, there
were Thomasians. All of them basically
believed in the deity of man and the
non-exclusive deity of Jesus Christ. All
of them.
Let's read what the Gospel of Peter had
to say that was dug up and you tell me
whether you think this is trustworthy.
Well, let's read it. By the way, these
Gnostic writings are apocryphal and
therefore they are sacred.
The cross talked and walked. Jesus had
died the day before uttering his last
words, "My power, oh power, you have
left me behind." His body was taken down
and placed in the tomb, but now as the
Sabbath dawned, oops. Which day is now
the Sabbath?
Sunday has become the Sabbath here.
The Sabbath as Sunday was kept only in
Alexandria and the Egyptian realm and in
Rome. The rest of the world kept
Sabbath, the seventh day. So, in this
one, the Sabbath has moved to Sunday.
Sabbath dawned, a great voice came from
the sky. Is that trustworthy? Well,
let's see how rest how trustworthy the
rest is. A great voice came from the sky
and two men descended. The stone
blocking the tomb rolled away of its own
accord. The Bible doesn't say that.
And while Roman soldiers gaped, three
men emerged from the tomb, two of them
supporting the other. Oh, Jesus couldn't
walk when he came out. His resurrection
was, you know, not quite that
illustrious.
With the cross following behind. Oh, all
by itself.
Was the cross buried with him? No, the
cross walked behind. Why? Because they
made the cross a very prominent symbol
in those days. The heads of the two
reached up to the sky, but the head of
the one they were leading went up above
the sky. And they heard a voice, "Have
you preached to those who are sleeping?"
So, here we have doctrine of preaching
to the dead and reply came from the
cross, "Yes."
Do you trust this Gospel? If you do, I
feel sorry for you. I think it belongs
where that other one was found, in the
trash.
Let me take you to Sinai.
Well, I was interested to go to St.
Catherine's where this manuscript, this
famous manuscript on which all modern
translations are based, was found.
Here it is, St. Catherine's
protectorate.
This is the monastery, the famous
monastery. Here are the skulls of the
monks that were active there. And if you
like, you can pray to them and get a
blessing.
They will answer you, apparently. I I
didn't see any possibility of answering
me. They had no breath in them, but
nevertheless,
you can, if you want to.
This is Sinai, so they say.
And in the church, you find these
symbols of sun and moon and all the
pagan symbols, the famous Sinai library,
where this was found, where you have all
these ancient handwritten codices, these
ancient manuscripts, and the famous
Codex Sinaiticus, which was found by
Tischendorf in 1844.
So, there we have it.
So, it was handed over to Catholic
scholars in 1844
and
from the University of Leipzig.
Interesting date. That's Codex
Sinaiticus.
And there you have some of the ancient
manuscripts that are in that place.
And uh
some interesting history about this
monastery. The bene- benevolent
treatment of the monastery of Sinai by
the Arabs, it was never destroyed by the
Arabs. So, Islam had no quarrel with
them.
Who took the peninsula in the 7th
century is due to the patent of Muhammad
and its protection with rights and
privileges, which Prophet Muhammad,
founder of Islam, granted to the monks
of the monastery of Sinai. So, Muhammad
protected this monastery. Who else
protected it? Well, here's another
interesting document. Napoleon
Bonaparte, who was a 33° Freemason, by
the way, if there was such a thing in
those days. His brother was the grand
master in Spain and he was a high
Freemason. Those degrees had not yet
existed at that stage to that degree,
but he was one of the highest initiates.
He protected this monastery. Interesting
people protected this monastery. This is
the famous four Gospels of Codex
Sinaiticus.
That's my friend over there. We are
going into the monastery.
And some of the paintings in the
monastery. And then this fascinating
bush over here with all these people
lining up to pray in front of this bush.
This is a famous bush.
In fact, this bush has survived for
thousands of years and has never ever
been watered.
Never been watered.
In fact, it is one of the most famous
bushes
in the history of the world.
It is the famous burning bush
that Moses bowed down to, so they say.
They told us it had never been watered.
I was inquiring what that pipe was
there.
But they in- insisted that it was a a
dead pipe, which it was. There was no
water in it. But I it's a very prickly
bush, so I was wondering whether there
was another one behind it, perhaps.
Nevertheless,
you can pray to the bush and it can give
you a blessing. I didn't want to pray
for that. May- I thought maybe touching
it will help, but I haven't felt
anything since then.
Now, this is the type of paganism that
is being taught there. Isn't it
incredible?
And these are two deacons sitting
outside.
Wherever the so-called
counter-reformation started by the
Jesuits gained hold of the people, the
vernacular was suppressed and the Bible
kept from the laity.
So eager were the Jesuits to destroy the
authority of the Bible,
the paper pope of the Protestants,
that's what they called it, as they
contemptuously called it, that they even
did not refrain from criticizing its
genuous and historical value. The
Jesuits made war against the Protestant
Bible.
Before the English people could go
the way of the continent and be brought
to the question their great English
Bible,
the course of their thinking must first
be changed.
Much had to be done to discredit in
their eyes the Reformation, its history,
doctrines, documents, which they look
looked upon as the great work of God.
So, this is what they had to do. They
had to destroy this thinking.
Now, a very interesting statement and
we'll see who it comes from in a moment.
Despite all the persecution they, the
Jesuits, have met with, this is a Roman
Catholic speaking, they have not
abandoned England where there are a
greater number of Jesuits than in Italy.
Take note.
Greater number of Jesuits than in Italy.
There are Jesuits in all classes of
society, in Parliament, among the
English clergy, among the Protestant
laity, even in the higher stations. I
could not comprehend how Jesuit could be
a Protestant priest or how Protestant
priest could be a Jesuit. But my
confessor silenced my scruples by
telling me omnia mundi mundus.
And that St. Paul became a Jew that he
might save the Jews, it was no wonder
therefore that if a Jesuit should feign
himself a Protestant for the conversion
of a Protestant. But pay attention, I
entreat you, to discover concerning the
nature of the religious movement in
England turned Puseyism.
The English clergy were formerly too
much attached to their article of faith
to be shaken from them.
You might have employed in vain all the
machines set in motion by Bossuet and
the Jansenists from France. That's the
ones who were, you know, behind the
French Revolution, the Jesuits and all
of that, to reunite them with the Romish
Church. So, the Jesuits of England tried
another plan.
This was to demonstrate from history and
ecclesiastical antiquity the legitimacy
of the usage of the English Church,
whence through the exertion of the
Jesuits concealed amongst its clergy
might arise a studious attention to
Christian antiquity.
Who wrote this?
Who wrote this that the Jesuits were the
priests in the Protestant churches?
It was Des Contes, priest at Rome,
professor of theology, official
theological censor of the Inquisition.
The man himself tells us that it was so.
Now, Romanism is known to have recently
entered the Church of England.
Before 1833,
if you held a mass like they hold it
today, that was an anathema. If you did
the things and said the things they said
then, that was an anathema. Afterwards,
things changed.
Newman, leader of the Oxford Movement,
that's their university, only through
the English Church can you act upon the
English nation.
I wish, of course, our church should be
consolidated
with and through and in your communion
for its sake and your sake and for the
sake of unity. He and his associates
believed that Protestantism was the
Antichrist.
Okay. Faber, one of the associates of
Newman, he was also in the Oxford
Movement, he said, "Protestantism is
perishing. What is good in it is by
God's mercy being gathered into the
garners of Rome. My whole life, God
willing, shall be one crusade against
the detestable and diabolical heresy of
Protestantism."
So, here is a war in in English Church.
I believe, he said Antichrist will be
infidel and arise out of what calls
itself Protestantism. So, he's just
turning it around.
And the church of Rome and England will
be united in one to oppose it.
Fascinating stuff.
Revelation 13:18 they changed
uh they didn't change the number 666,
but in the revised version they have a
footnote which says and his number is
616.
Just went to say.
Now, let's get to these two gentlemen,
Westcott and Hort. These are the ones
that wrote
based on the ancient manuscript, the
Greek text upon which all modern
translations are based. Who were these
two gentlemen and what did they believe?
Now, everything I'm going to say about
them comes from books written by the
sons of Westcott and Hort publishing
their own letters. So, this is not what
somebody says about them. This is they
themselves saying what they believe.
This is the horse's mouth. Wonderful to
have quotes like that. They probably
wish they had never done that after this
lecture.
Hort as well as Westcott rejected the
idea of infallibility of the Bible,
called the doctrine of substitutionary
atonement that Jesus died for you, he
called it immoral.
He denied the historicity of Genesis. He
praised Darwin and he denied the
divinity of Christ. Does it sound
familiar?
Who were these people? Uh Professor
Westcott and Hort. Well, Westcott was
born in 1825, Hort born in 1828. They
were members of the Broad Church, the
High Church party of the Church of
England. They became friends during
their student days at Cambridge
University, worked together. Westcott
became Bishop of Durham and Hort is best
remembered as Professor of Divinity at
Cambridge University.
Well, their doctrines are so Jesuit that
I wouldn't be surprised if they were two
of these illustrious gentlemen.
Hort's view on evolution, he says the
beginning of an individual is precisely
as inconceivable as the beginning of a
species. It certainly startles me to
find you saying that you have seen no
facts which support such a view as
Darwin's. But he was a Darwinist. And uh
he says his book drove me to the
conclusion that some kind of development
must be supposed. So, he was a
Darwinist.
This is a letter from Hort to Macmillan.
He writes, "Another word on Darwin, I
shall not let the subject drop in a
hurry or to speak more correctly, it
will not let me drop." And so, he
continues to say that he is a Darwinist.
Here is another letter from Hort to
Westcott. "Have you read Darwin? How I
should like to talk with you about it."
And another letter to Ellerton, "But the
book which has most engaged me is
Darwin." Just We don't have to read the
whole quote, you can read it yourself.
He says Darwin's arguments are
irrefutable, unanswerable.
Another letter of Hort to Ellerton, "I
had no idea till the last few weeks of
the importance of the texts." These are
the new ones that had now been found.
"Having read so little Greek Testament
and dragged on with the villainous
Textus Receptus."
So, he calls the received text
villainous.
Think of that vile Textus Receptus.
Doesn't that sound like a Jesuit?
Who hated the received text, who called
it that asp, that serpent?
"Leaning entirely on late manuscripts."
There comes their argument, the Sinaitic
text was early. "It is a blessing there
are such early ones."
Then Hort to Reverend Ellerton, "One
result of our talk I may as well tell
you, he, Westcott and I are going to
edit the Greek text of the New Testament
some two or three years hence if
possible." And he talks about Lachmann
and Tischendorf who will supply the
materials.
And then uh
he says, "Our object is to supply
clergymen generally, schools, etc. with
a portable Greek text which shall not be
disfigured
with Byzantine corruptions."
In other words, it won't contain what
the
received text contains. How are they
going to do this?
Another letter, Westcott to Hort, "As to
our proposed recension of the New
Testament text, our object should be, I
suppose, to prepare a text for common
and general use. With such an end in
view, would it not be best
to introduce only certain emendations?
Only change it a little bit here and a
little bit there
into the received text and to take note
in the margin such as seem likely or
noticeable of the Griesbach's manner."
You know, if we change it completely,
these British will get nervous.
Let's just here
and there and write in the margin what
we think is important. So, that when
they read it and they read the
manuscript margin, they'll see, "Oh,
yes.
We see that this probably shouldn't be
there because an early manuscript,
corrupt one, they don't say that, it
doesn't have it."
You see what I mean? That's what they've
decided. "I feel most keenly disgraced
of circulating what I feel to be
falsified copies of Holy Scripture."
That's a reference to the
uh
authorized version. "And I'm most
anxious to provide something to replace
them.
This cannot be any text resting solely
on our own judgment even if we were not
too inexperienced to make one."
So, he's quite willing to write another
Bible all by himself.
"But it must be supported by a clear and
obvious preponderance of evidence. The
margin
will give ample scope for our own
ingenuity
or principle. So, I suggest when you
read the margins, distrust them
completely."
"My wish would be to leave the popular
received text except where it is clearly
wrong." In his opinion, of course.
Then he says this interesting thing.
Westcott,
"Gorham, Benson, Bradshaw, Lord and I
have started a society for the
investigation of ghosts." Okay, they
were spiritists.
"And all supernatural appearances and
effects being all disposed to believe
that such things really exist and ought
to be discriminated from hoaxes and mere
subjective delusions." And uh
they called it all kinds of names,
and bull club, etc. etc. And out of this
developed an incredible society.
In 1882, the Society for Psychical
Research was founded. In effect, it was
a combination of those groups already
working independently.
So, they work with telepathy,
clairvoyance, etc.
And uh this is ancient occult wisdom.
And
Cambridge University Ghost Society was
founded by no less a person than Edward
White Benson, future Archbishop of
Canterbury together with these
illustrious persons and Darwin also
attended.
Now,
this society, the Society for Psychical
Research is also the society which runs
the esoteric side of the New Age
movement today with its channeling and
its communication with the spirit world.
All of these things are in there.
Among the numerous persons and groups
who were in the middle of the 19th
century were making inquiries,
there you will see Edward White Benson,
Archbishop of Canterbury, his son A.C.
Benson
uh will be found under the year 1851
with the following paragraph.
"Among my father's diversions at
Cambridge was the foundation of a ghost
society." And then people like Lightfoot
and Westcott and Hort were among the
members. There it is.
He was then always more interested in
psychical phenomenon and than he cared
to admit.
Very well. So,
the evolution from traditional
mediumship to contemporary chan-
channeling has been gradual. The
original spiritualism started in 1848.
Then came the Society of Psychical
Research in Britain. And then Helena
Petrovna Blavatsky. He took this up and
continued. And she's the one that wrote,
"Lucifer is the Logos, the serpent, the
savior. Satan is the only God of this
planet." That's what she wrote. That's
where it came from. The Secret Doctrine
comes from this group. Now, did they
belong to any other secret societies?
The answer is yes.
Hort was a member of a secret society.
He found time to attend the meeting
of various societies in June, joined the
mysterious company of the Apostles.
He remained always a grateful and loyal
member of the secret club which has now,
1896, become famous for the number of
distinguished men who have belonged to
it.
In his time, the club was in a manner
reinvigorated and he, this is Hort, was
mainly responsible for the wording of
the oath which binds the members to a
conspiracy of silence.
Did he belong to a secret society? Yes
or no?
Yes.
Which binds them to silence. Does this
sound Masonic to you? Yes or no?
Well, the Prime Minister of England was
also in there and he wrote the
constitution for the League of Nations
where he insisted that all religions
should become one and wrote an esoteric
solution to that which is also Masonic.
So, these people were Masons. Now, we
saw yesterday that the high initiates
believed that who is God?
The devil is God.
Satan is God. Lucifer is God.
So, Mr. Hort, are you going to rewrite
the Bible while you believe that Lucifer
is the son of God?
Doesn't that mean that Jesus must be
made less than he is? Yes or no?
Wouldn't they want to rewrite the Bible
so that Jesus is written out of the
Constitution? Yes or no?
Well, do we find that today or don't we?
That's the question. I'm not going to
answer it tonight. We'll answer it
tomorrow.
We'll see for ourselves. Bring your
Bibles along. Let's have a look.
1854, Hort to Reverend John Ellerton. I
agree with you in thinking it is a pity
that Maurice verbally repudiates
purgatory.
But I fully and unwavering agree with
him in the three cardinal points of the
controversy. That's certain
that eternity is independent of
duration, that the power of repentance
is not limited to this life.
Can you believe this? He believes in
purgatory and that you can repent on the
other side.
That it is not revealed whether or not
all will be will ultimately repent. The
modern denial of the second has I
suppose had more to do with the
de-spiritualizing of theology than
almost anything that could be named.
Okay. He believed the Roman Catholic
doctrine of purgatory.
Does he say anything further on it? Here
he is advising a young student. He
wrote, "The idea of purgation,
purgatory, burning your sins off on the
other side, of cleansing as by fire
seems to me inseparable from what the
Bible teaches us."
So, is he teaching Jesuit doctrine or is
he teaching Protestant doctrine? You
tell me.
He's teaching Jesuit doctrine.
But it's very clever
to say he's a Protestant so that
Protestants will accept his Bible
because this
Bible now comes from a Protestant's pen.
If you don't know.
So,
teaches us that divine chastisement and
little and though little is directly
said respecting the future state, it
seems to me incredible that the divine
chastisement should in this respect
change their character when this visible
life is ended. So, he believes in
purgatory.
What does he say about the atonement?
That Jesus died for you?
Well, here is his letter in life, volume
1, page 322.
I think I mentioned to you before
Campbell's book on the atonement, which
is invaluable as far as it goes, but
unluckily he knows nothing except
Protestant theology.
Okay. What does he say?
Letter,
Hort to Westcott.
I entirely agree
correcting one word with what you there
say on the atonement, having for many
years believed that the absolute union
of the Christian
or rather of man with Christ himself is
the spiritual truth of which the popular
doctrine of substitution
is an immoral and material counterfeit.
Wow.
So, Jesus died for you is a immoral
doctrine. Rather, what is moral that we
become one with him in Christ and become
God.
That's moral.
Now, who teaches that?
The Jesuits
and the Freemasons or the Bible? Who
teaches that?
Well, what was this man? Belonged to a
secret society,
had a psychic club, and not only that,
he hates the received text,
and he spits on the atonement. That's
like a Templar. That's spitting on the
cross.
Certainly nothing can be more
unscriptural than the modern limiting of
Christ's bearing our sins
and sufferings to his death, but indeed
that is only one aspect of an almost
universal heresy.
Okay.
These are the people who have trans
who've created the document on which the
modern Bibles are based.
Do you believe they're trustworthy?
I don't think so.
Here's another letter, Hort to Reverend
Davies. No rational being doubts the
need for a revised Bible.
And the popular practical objections are
worthless. Yet I have an increasing
feeling in favor of delay.
He was having problems because
the British still knew their Bibles. Of
course, no revision can be final and it
would be absurd to wait for perfection,
but the criticism of both Testament in
text and interpretation alike appears to
me to be just now in this chaotic state.
In Germany, hardly as if all the less in
England, that the results of immediate
revision would be peculiarly
unsatisfactory.
Oh, the British knew their Bibles. This
was a problem. We have to be careful and
sneaky with what we are going to do.
Then he says,
Well, let's first read what it says down
here. It is of course true that we can
only know God through human forms, but
then I think the whole Bible echoes the
language of Genesis 1:27
and so assures us that human forms are
divine forms. Gotcha, Mr. Hort.
What is he saying?
He's saying we are God.
We are God. Who teaches that?
Satan teaches that.
Now, listen to this. 1 John 5:7
in the King James.
For there are three that bear record in
heaven,
the Father,
the Word, and the Holy Ghost, and these
three are one.
What does that make Jesus?
Makes him God.
You will search in vain in the modern
Bibles for that verse. You won't find it
in the NIV. You won't find it in the
RSV. It's been removed
so that they can be God.
Hort to Westcott. I have been persuaded
for many years that Mary worship and
Jesus worship have very much in common
in their causes and their results.
Perhaps the whole question may be said
to be involved in the true idea of
mediation,
which is almost universally corrupted in
one or both of the opposite directions.
Huh. So, who can mediate for you just as
well?
Mary can. Is that Catholic doctrine or
biblical doctrine?
What about the other man?
Westcott writes, "I've been trying to
recall my impressions of La Salette.
That's interesting. La Salette. We'll be
talking about La Salette,
a Marian shrine.
I wish I could see what forgotten truth
mariolatry bears witness and how we can
practically set forth the teachings of
the miracles."
Well, Mr. Westcott,
so you want to bring mariolatry in
and make Jesus less?
Westcott to Reverend Benson. As far as I
could judge, the idea of La Salette was
that of God revealing himself now and
not in one form, but in many.
See? Ecumenism. Fascinating stuff.
Hort to Reverend Rowland. There are I
fear still more serious differences
between us on the subject of authority
and especially the authority of the
Bible.
If this primary objection were removed
and I could feel our differences to be
only a degree, I would still blah blah
blah. So,
he wants to go away from this idea that
the Bible is inspired and uh the errors
errors and prejudices which we agree in
wishing to remove can
surely be more wholesomely and also more
effectively reached by individual
efforts of an indirect kind
than by combined open assault. Let's
work behind the scenes, sneakily and
quietly so that we don't bring about the
premature crisis. These people were
clever.
Though I think that convocation is not
competent to initiate such a measure,
yet I feel that as we three
are together, it would be wrong not to
make the best of it as Lightfoot says.
Indeed, there is a very fair prospect of
good work if we three stick together.
Though neither with this body nor any
other body likely to be formed now could
a complete textual revision be possible.
We can't change everything now. Let's do
it bit by bit. We stick together, we
three. There is some hope that
alternative readings might find a place
in the margin.
So, as we go from translation to
translation, you find some in the margin
and in the next version, oops, they're
gone.
Axed away.
And so the Bible changes.
Do you know if you pick up your Bibles
and you turn to the middle of the book
of Acts,
if you take an NIV Bible and you go to
the middle of the book of Acts, and then
you page and look how many words there
are to the end of Revelation, that's how
many words are gone
out of the modern Bibles. From the
middle of Acts to the end of Revelation.
Now, if man is not to live by bread
alone, but by every word that proceeds
out of the mouth of the Lord, how are
you going to do that with so many words
gone?
Up to 60,000 of them gone.
Ought we not to have a conference before
the first meeting for revision? There
are many points on which it is important
that we should agree.
The rules, though liberal, are vague and
the interpretation of them will depend
upon decided action at first.
It is quite impossible to judge the
value of what appears to be trifling
alterations. Now, please note this one
for tomorrow's lecture.
It is quite impossible to judge the
value of what it will appear to be
trifling alterations.
A one word changed in a text so that
people don't even notice it.
Trifling alterations merely by reading
them one after another.
Taken together,
they have often important bearings which
few would think of at first. Are you
with me on this one?
We'll change the Bible
a tad there and a
tad there.
And if we take it all together, well,
we'll have entirely different doctrines
and those stupid won't even have
noticed. That's what he's saying.
Well, we're going to do that tomorrow.
I'm going to show you trifling little
changes
and you will be shocked
as to what they did to Jesus Christ
our Lord.
You will hopefully be shocked.
Remember, trifling little changes.
The difference between a picture, say of
Raphael, and a feeble copy of it is made
up of a number of trivial differences.
Isn't that interesting? We have
successfully resisted being warned of
dangerous ground where the needs of
revision required that it should be
shirked. It is, one can hardly doubt,
the beginning of a new period in church
history. So far, the angry objections
have reason for their astonishment.
These people are subtle.
Balfour
was a member of Hort's apostles and uh
president of the the society for psychic
research. As I said, he was prime
minister of England and he wrote the
first draft for the League of Nations or
he was responsible, partly responsible
at least, in that.
So, these were high-flying individuals.
Let's look at this interesting extract
from a book, Which Bible, by David
Fuller. Hort writes to Reverend Rowland
Williams, October 21, 1858.
Further, I agree with them,
that's authors of Essays and Reviews, in
condemning many leading specific
doctrines of the popular theology.
Evangelical seem to me perverted rather
than untrue. There are, I fear, still
more serious difference between us and
the subject of authority, especially the
authority of the Bible. He doesn't
believe in the authority of the Bible.
He writes from France. After leaving the
monastery, we shaped our course to the
little oratory which we discovered on
the summit of a neighboring hill.
Fortunately, we found the door open and
there was this pieta the size of life,
Virgin and the dead Christ. Had I been
alone, I would have knelt there for
hours. This is a Roman Catholic
speaking. This is not a Protestant.
If he wasn't a Jesuit, I'll eat my hat.
Westcott writes to the Archbishop of
Canterbury, an Old Testament criticism.
No one now, I suppose, holds that the
first three chapters of Genesis
give a literal history. I could never
understand how anyone reading them with
open eyes could think they did. They
didn't believe anything.
And these are the best manuscripts in
the world. Do you believe it?
I'm inclined to think that no such state
as Eden ever existed.
And that Adam's fall in no degree
differed from the fall of each of his
descendants. There was no fall. This is
occult teaching.
Hort writes, "The pure Romish view seems
to be nearer and more likely to lead to
the truth than the Evangelical. So, Rome
is right and the other one is wrong."
Hort writes to Westcott, "I remember
shocking you and Lightfoot not so long
ago by exposing a belief that
Protestantism is only parenthetical and
temporary. We'll get rid of it yet.
It's in the way. It's a null.
It's a nauseating interference at the
moment."
So, we've seen now
firstly,
when we look at the history of where
these manuscripts come from,
that the manuscripts
have three streams. Two of them are
akin. They're only two streams based on
very few manuscripts
leading to these changes.
Corrupted probably by Origen and
continued by Eusebius.
Then these people pick up these texts
and say, "These are the oldest
manuscripts. Therefore, they are the
best and we will base the new
translations on these manuscripts and
throw aside the received text."
Deuteronomy 11:16 says, "Take heed to
yourself that your heart be not deceived
and you turn aside and serve other gods
and worship them."
First Timothy 4:16 says, "Take heed unto
thyself unto the doctrine."
"Continue in them, for in doing this
thou shalt both save thyself and them
that hear thee."
What if the texts are so changed
that you cannot support your doctrines
anymore? What would you do then?
Did you know that the doctrine
of the dead, state of the dead, cannot
be adequately supported from new
manuscripts?
Do you know that the divinity of Christ
is a problem
because a comma here and a little change
there and something there changes the
whole picture?
Do you know that Jesus turns up to be
the liar and the other one turns out to
be more truthful if you read it in the
new manuscripts? It's quite interesting.
I invite you to come tomorrow and
listen. Second Corinthians 2:17 says,
"For we are not as many which corrupt
the word of God,
but as of sincerity,
but as of God, and in the sight of God,
speak we in Christ." If Jesus isn't
everything and everything in our lives,
then we have nothing.
If Jesus isn't God,
we have nothing to look forward to.
The best we could hope for is a constant
cycle of reincarnation into a miserable
world. Now as a human, now as an animal,
perhaps as a leaf to be eaten by a cow.
Quite a miserable existence as far as
I'm concerned.
But if Jesus Christ is the way, the
truth, and the life,
and he has paid the price for my sins, I
have a way out.
I have a solution
to the problem I am facing in the first
place and I have an answer
to all my inner questions.
Because I know where I come from.
I come from a noble origin.
I know why I am in the state that I am.
I have fallen because of sin.
And I have need of redemption which I
can find only in him who made me in the
first place.
And this is the doctrine that is under
attack. Darwinism is supposed to rule
in the place of creation. As we've seen,
this is what these people believe. The
atonement is to be written away
so that Jesus doesn't fulfill that role
anymore. And a Zoroaster and Osiris must
become his equal.
In fact, I must become his equal
because I'm just as good as he is.
I'm also divine, so they claim.
Either the one is true or the other.
And then we have to answer ask another
question.
Why is Rome these days silent
about the Bible
but still rants and raves about the
received text?
Why is it attacked everywhere in every
single college of theology?
Why do they say in the colleges of
theology, "The very worst text in the
world is the received text.
Throw it aside. Here is something better
for you."
Come and see tomorrow
how much better it is
and see for yourselves. Thank you.
>> Mhm.